so gibt neue folge neues thema hunger
games sehr gut macht spaß pro spiel die
den ganzen minecraft suchen bei alledem
ist halt wenn man das mit leuten spielt
die das schon die ganze map vorher sich
ausgeguckt haben und sich eine taktik
zeug gelegt haben und dann halt genau
den lauf und du als jemand der sich noch
nicht angeschaut hat dann keine chance
hat das ist halt mehr viel scheiße
langweilig dumm aber an sich ist eine
ziemlich coole sache aber häufig sind
hier unten halt doch relativ langweilig
im endeffekt doch die map sohn bisher
eigentlich nicht immer besser
also ich gehe eigentlich überhaupt nicht
gerne hunger games hast dich was willst
du denn hier überhaupt noch an ergänzte
ich spiele spielt oder nicht keine
ahnung so überzeugt ich da braucht man
schon richtig eklige map meiner meinung
nach also die vierte jetzt draußen ist
so hundertprozentig nicht ist einzelne
flatland map die zwar fand ich die beste
sein beste obwohl ich glaube ich
insgesamt mit meiner ganzen leben nur
vier mal hunger games oder so gespielt
habe kann ich hab nur wenn ich
aufgenommen habt es gespielt habe und
wie häufig habe ich auf m3 alles was
zwei mal mit mir hat nein ich habe eine
treppe noch die falsch gesetzt
mainhausen in form an
das ist unmöglich habe ich so eine
schöne galerie und so eng ich ja so
schön ich glaube versetzt die dinge sich
muss in den höhlen und dingens die hohe
story jetzt erst mal mein dach noch mal
weg weil ich das anders machen will
das kann eigentlich dass du aus gras
hast du gesagt obwohl da kann ich das
eine schöne dickens drauf er hat gras
geladen
er hat gesagt hdf klare aussage braucht
einer von euch drauf auch wenn eine
rauchen würde wird jetzt glaub ich nicht
fragen warum aber ich habe jetzt nicht
den namen zu und gar nichts aber wohl
auch schon brauchen als thema in die
kommentare schon mehrfach geschrieben
aber das ist das thema von dieser folge
gewesen games zu lappen alter märkten
entschuldigung zwei sekunden her immer
so wenig über das thema hab ich das
gefühl wir ihre wir gleiten da immer ab
wenn hunger games gut da also hgh
sondern auch ausführliche meinung von
häkchen 22 übrigens werten
ich hab's verständlich habe die
ausführlichste meinung nach malta und
nochmal von crafter zwingt mit naja also
der hunger games ist an sich ziemlich
epische maps jeder bauen eine ziemlich
coole idee das so in minecraft zu
aufzubauen startblöcken und alles
zusammen
aber die also ich denke mal es wirkt so
das konzept wirkt irgendwie epischer als
es dann im endeffekt ist weil es einfach
nicht so zusammen läuft und vor allem
wenn man dann der ist der so schnell
stirbt dann ist auch wieder nicht so
geil und alles ja das sollte mal wolle
treffen mit minecraft geben reule treibt
aber gute meine zusage games auf jeden
fall so ähnlich dass aber auch das
gleiche wie lena ja ich kann es
das kommt ja alles von dem film bzw von
dem buch und beides habe ich nicht
geguckt aber ich weiß dass es dort so
ist das ja lustig brown nicht geguckt
man kann jetzt nicht so umsetzen
das produkt hat jetzt endlich mal sozial
ich habe das buch nicht gelesen
certina hammer wie du im display
ich hab' ich habe das buch sogar gelesen
ich mich sein aber bevor er dass der
film draußen war draußen gewesen
erzählen die ganze zeit in meinem haus
und ich konnte keinen schritt weiter
irgendwie ich weiß nicht was das bringt
was ich doch ich konnte nicht habe ich
bp zu mietende minecraft park gesehen
haben sie das so genannte h das
unterscheidet man sich untergräbt und
dann dort also ich nenne es macht das
zeitalter zeiten
ich habe die zeit wirklich straight
mining ist mir auf webserver ich schon
minecraft gespielt haben als account
habe er den aber schon am 1 ja ich habe
auch das größte bild muss ich sagen es
wurde mir aber gemacht von jemanden
nachdem er mir weil sie nicht drei
designs geschickt habe ich absolut
scheiße fand kann man mit dem jahr an
das ist echt geil
echt schön ich kenne sie kann ewig
darauf schauen was die underground
könntest du ihn wissen was ja auch mal
was ist ein friedhof für alle leute die
da waren ja wohl denn alte tote wird
nachdem sie hier waren wir müssen uns so
eine sonne wall of fame machen das
machen auch die starter oder same ja da
kann sich jeder eintragen der hier so
war richtig gut
der star beim ein haus wer kommt die an
ob du ich einfach etwas machen was hast
du nebenbei mir ausgenommen so gar
nichts das werde ich eigentlich lagen
damit aber wenn ich dich zurückkehrt wo
liegt ein schwert du kannst du bringst
du mir geb ich laufe sport ist mord
motto what a
ich hab hier nicht hinterher hinterher
nicht so geht's nämlich die dum die
spinne werden
es war ja zur spinne oder sie spendet
august will ich die spinne stargast hier
noch einmal was nimmst du bist aber dran
wir bestätigen kriegst du runter nahm
das ist nur schwer
ich kann doch nicht so schwer
ich glaube ich bin zu blöd zum bauen
hier verkrochen
ich kenne schon wieder alles abreißen so
halb so warm ist ja holz wo halt bei mir
und im gang
das weiß ich nicht weil ist ein
minecraft paket gestorben
ich finde schon besser als lappen nicht
so lampen sondern eimer
junge ganz zu den englisch weil bucket
heißt nicht einmal eine das wäre zwar
geschrieben und ich werde mit doppel k
geschrieben
zkk nicht zkk
kannst du kein englisch das rezept gar
geschrieben wie sie glück gehabt
ich wäre schon fast wieder gestorben
jetzt gesagt wird einmal angebrochen
du bist dran gegangen da blieb mir
leider keine andere möglichkeit ist ab
so klaustrophobie da ist es klar oder
heißt es noch ungefähr so aber wirklich
schlimm damit was heißt klauen was für
eine phobie hat man dann klauen phobie
kein vorbild gibt es auch er klauen
phobie es gibt auch den es gibt die vier
phobie vor dem namen dieter was doch es
gibt auch so schulphobie und so was
bezahlt es gibt einen zu allen phobien
aber was für dieter natürlich von alter
wenn du selbst dieter heißt das wissen
wir machen ja auch nicht eingerichtet
man sich dann vor dem namen einfach nur
ein kratzer oder wat ass är steigen
gute frage wird man in der klasse der
spinnentiere biosprit hatten durfte
immer raus gehen und ihr freund warum
hast du nicht gesagt dass die spende
hast weil ich hart bin ja ich gedacht na
ja ekelhaft alam anda habe ich gleich
fertig noch nichts
das raumaufteilung noch nicht gesagt
beruhigt habe ich mich jetzt nicht aber
ich habe noch keine raumaufteilung wie
weit bist ich bin immer ruhig ich bin
ruhig komm gucken macht looki looki
titel einfahren
ich hatte auch mal bei dir vorbei
bei mir nicht
sailers umkreis gang gemacht hilfe
demonstrieren kreis kann gar nicht raus
auch hier seine tür
ich bin jetzt aufhören 49h notepad nein
das auch schlecht eigentlich gar keine
fenster zu bekommen ich wusste dass er
alles selbst erfahren
du hast alles gut wir eigentlich schon
alles klar
diese fanden von luke habe ich überhaupt
nichts geklaut aber das meiste kommt
eigentlich danach darum ist man die
ganzen sachen weg wollen wir dem
häuschen bauen am starthäuschen
statischen aus starten wird schon wieder
hallo hallo gehts nicht jetzt nichts
nichts verwertbares man komm her
gelaufen wo bist du immer gucken komm zu
mir du bist du denn es war als sie dazu
ja politisch du bist nicht du musst sich
teleportieren zu den sachen fdp
minecraft pocket erinnert da hinten bist
du doch jetzt hier unter lauf bin ich
jetzt eigentlich gestorben ein junger
mann stoppen
heute nicht genug eins zwei drei vier
fünf sechs sieben mal bei scor neuen
leben hast danach bist kannst du katze
so weltverband fia instanz aber hallo
leute in stent bsd